so we have something called coku
ho pretty and um Co
C we we Define it as the following okay
so it's alchemically treated yangong
aspect that is released at a higher
yangong value to the contact point that
that is co cute
right um we have koku so
kokuo is whole means method or means in
this case it's a different kanji from
the whole of sh n um which means for
direction that one means Direction okay
this kle this Ki means method or means
so kle means method of cultivating C or
method of cultivating alchemically
treated Yang aspect and releasing it at
a higher Yang value to the contact point
with ukin okay the short form of that
is um projection That's What I Call
projection okay otherwise it's
long um what happens if I release
alchemically treated yangong aspect not
at a higher Yong value than the contact
point would UK get well for example if I
release it at an equal y value to the
contact point there that generates I ke
okay so here if you look at it the means
by which CQ is developed and the means
by which I ke is developed though that
means is the same it's what value are
you releasing that alchemically treated
uh Y is it greater than the contact
point with UK or is it equal to the
contact Point okay if it's greater than
you'll see ukip project or as some of
you have referred to it is bounce off
they bounce off you okay uh if it's
equal to then uh they'll adhere they'll
get stuck they'll feel like a friction
there like velcro or something and they
can't get off of it
okay um they have to counter that
adhesion okay that's what I call an
adhesion all right uh in normal coku
hole it assumes you're doing that but as
we know because everyone practices khole
and no one has internal skills as I just
described that it must not work
okay
um meaning you can do the technique coku
ho without doing kokuo you know mean you
can do what has come to be known as C ho
but you're not actually cultivating C
you're not doing the internal
Alchemy so to help shed light on that
what we've done here is we've brought a
spontaneous training environment to this
alchemical cultivation
drill um and as I always like to do kill
as many birds with one stone as possible
so in doing this drill now
spontaneously
[Music]
um you will have to use a intermediate
range grappling skill which is called
following okay so ieto Kaza functions at
a range greater than like the clinch but
closer than uh blocking and striking and
in order to make that range V ible
martially you need to know how to uh
stick and adhere or follow and adhere
okay you need to know how to do that
because once she feels an adhesion she's
going to try to get out of it like
anyone else would and you will lose
contact with them if you don't know how
to follow if you know how to follow
their counter to the adhesion just sets
up the next adhesion or the next
projection point and so we're working on
that as well in this drill so again to
repeat one we have a drill where you
can't fake you're doing culk cultivation
of alchemically treated young aspect and
two we brought in another Marshall skill
that is just assumed in kol assume in
iido Konan that is the ability to follow
okay so that's what we're we're doing in
this draw so you task in this game that
she's trying to hit me in the chest okay
and I'm trying not to let her hit me in
the chest okay she can do whatever she
wants to do I would use the other hand
since I'm grabbing this
hand okay she can do whatever she wants
okay and very quickly you learn like if
I grab something I'm open to the other
one it just happens too fast okay
um so usually you'll go like you you'll
start to work this stuff you see and but
eventually she'll counter that just gets
out of it and she hits the chest okay
and so it sets up the need for Ike and
cooku which is assumed in this mid-range
grappling uh because you can't really
grab things to keep control of somebody
and two you can't deflect things to keep
control of somebody at this range
eventually they're going to get through
um here it's a simple game of touch the
chest but if you make that a knife then
I'm dead Okay so uh a couple things also
we keep it seated so that we don't take
advantage of our footwork and our
Mobility to deal with our inability to
project adhere and follow okay that's
why we do this so I don't I don't like
to see people moving around and stuff
because uh now it's not working we're
not making it hard enough to make this
work okay so a couple things as we go
she she goes is I don't want to be
reaction so she went and I went that's
not how it is so just like in all the
weapons work I'm already in a psycho
spiritual adhesion with her or communion
so I can feel her intention she goes and
I reach for her so on that one she you
went for this hand right hey let me slow
down cuz it's probably too fast but
you'll see that my hand came to you and
then the other hand was already waiting
if you paid attention it wasn't that I
went here and then you went there and I
went like that so you guys are not
seeking the connection okay and so
you're not preceding the physical
connection with the spiritual connection
okay so the way simple thing is you're
like I don't know what the you mean
by a spiritual connection all right
reach out and reach out for them you're
going to be better off okay so you go
and I reach for you now I make contact
okay and now if I stay here where it's
just a flexion you you can feel that you
don't really have to do anything I think
you could push through that
youy or maybe I push on your skin and
you can feel what do you want to do yep
she wants to go around it okay as
opposed to when I reach out and other
there that's weird okay something I
don't know you have to describe it I
feel like there's a wall there's a wall
there but if you pay attention is there
a place to get around
it not in a subtle way right you got to
make a big movement to get around it and
then what else you noticed is your
joints got all locked look how weird
you're look at your weird body right now
okay so stay there if you can I'll find
you again but you're like this you see
whereas in the beginning look how
comfortable you are you're you know you
can move all your joints but boom and
we're here again the joints get locked
okay and then pay attention to your
posture you're in a lean as opposed to
here okay so as as soon as I touch where
however I touch so however I touch I
want those joints locked and I want your
posture compromised okay and um you'll
do whatever cuz if you don't then I'm
going to get you do you
see so she'll do whatever she got out of
it but I just rolled that in so let's go
over here okay so she's trying to do
this
counter go around it like you did do you
see okay only we're in this
tilt so when she goes around it and then
I take it more into the Tilt do you see
and then the joints are more
locked and that's that follow part okay
so here's the joints and the posture you
try to get out of it and I followed it
to the next adhesion point so I'm going
to let go of this side even though it
helps with the adhesion and this is what
I mean you see how it
it has a pulling energy to it okay has a
pulling energy right clearly but if you
went over here go ahead and get out of
it get out of it and push on my hand NOP
push on my hand this way and you see
that it had that wall effect too you
see okay so I reach for you and I get
you in that
same thing you see it's right there even
your breathing has stopped
okay so then you would get around it
however and I take it into the next one
again so it looks like khole in a way if
you grab you grab it looks like khole in
that as soon as you touch you can do it
but you can't tell in the camera that
she was trying to get around in all
these different ways okay so what I like
to do is give you chances to get out you
see so I'll like hold you here and let
you move
the other thing I'll do is
uh start it like and I'll pull I I like
to feel CU I'm trying to cultivate those
skills right there's no need to to pull
you but you could feel that great
friction on your hand right and so that
is the IC feel like I'm going to emit
the Y
value equal to the hand
contact like there's no point in
martially to do that but in terms of
cultivating the skill I am cultivating
it you see so sometimes I do that uh
sometimes I know I have you here but I
pull you back into into the technique
again to give you another
chance this is this one's all go back
here she goes around it that's all
following there but as we as she follow
as I follow I take it right into the
connection again you see it's right
here then the next thing I do is um I
have to resist the
temptation to contrast you to contest
you okay so and that's what allows me to
get in Crazy situations and have fun
with this kind of stuff um as opposed to
you go and I'm like here and I'm doing
this kind of stuff trying to shut you
down you see that you you can move
pretty
freely and so with that I can talk you
can keep doing with that
I try to always
release
the uh reactionary
tension in my
body so that's me holding her in that in
that balance with the adhesion and the
fluctuation to the coke
you okay
it's different huh okay you